so
this is stop writing tests in which i
will be somewhat provocative but i'm
also kind of serious about this where
i think that while many projects are
under-tested we should
nonetheless spend less time writing
tests by hand than we do at the moment
but before we really jump into it i want
to start with an australian tradition
called an acknowledgement of country
this image is my hometown of canberra i
live just off to the left and work kind
of in the central foreground at the
australian national university
but before
the town of canberra was here before the
australian national university was here
this was the land of the dunawal and the
derbury peoples for tens of thousands of
years and i want to pay remiss my
respects to their elders past and
present and their leaders emerging and
acknowledged that their land and waters
were never seated
the main body of my talk though is about
testing and so it behooves me to quickly
define testing it's that thing where you
run your code and check whether or not
it did the right thing
usually we're either looking to find new
bugs or checking for regressions these
are often kind of separate activities
even if we use the same tools for each
of them the workflows are often quite
different
but fundamentally the checklist goes
like choose inputs run the thing we want
to test check that it did the right
thing or that it didn't do the wrong
thing and then repeat as necessary
so let's use an example
in deference to my friend david who
probably doesn't want to drink quite so
much as this tweet would indicate
uh instead of talking about sorting and
reversing a list sorry we're going to
look at sorting a list as our example
so here's some simple tests we might
write for the sorted built-in you know
if for some reason we've lost all trust
in the python core developers but still
used python
we can see here that if we sort the list
one two three we get the list one two
three and if we sort the list three two
one we get one two three even if they're
floats and that preserves the output
type and we can see that we can sort
strings as well as numbers so that's
kind of nice and if we're thinking like
don't repeat ourselves
well like all good software engineers we
might use a pi test parametrize
so in this case we've got semantically
the same test but we list out our input
and output data
and then have a kind of data driven or
table driven parametrized test
so this really helps reduce boilerplate
it okay to be honest when you've only
got three it hasn't helped much but it
makes it much easier to add further
input output pairs in the future
the problem is that this isn't really
automated testing like the mechanical
turk of contemporary amazon or of the
1800s magicians trick what we have done
is not so much automated a process as
hidden the human labor involved in it
and i'm going to claim that not only is
this not particularly automated it also
doesn't scale particularly well
so what can we do that would make
writing these kinds of tests easier
well one thing would be to go is there a
way that would let us get away from
having to define the output so we only
had to think up the inputs because here
remember we have to define by hand what
is the correct result for every possible
input
so here we only have to come up with the
input and by comparing it to a trusted
equivalent sort function we can
automatically check that it behaved
correctly
so we've already saved ourselves a chunk
of work with this approach and you might
be thinking like how often do i have a
trusted alternative version
well every time you're refactoring the
version before the refactor and the
version afterwards should do exactly the
same thing
or if you have multi-threaded code if
you run it with one thread or with many
threads it should do the same thing
or even you might have like a mock
version of your database that fits in
memory instead of being a distributed
system you can check the equivalence of
these kinds of things as well
but even if you don't have that kind of
thing all is not lost
we can leverage particular properties
that's why it's called property-based
testing of our functions
and so for the sorted built-in we know
that no matter what the input should be
the output should always be in ascending
order right if you take the pairs of
numbers or elements of the output then
the first one should always be less than
or equal to the second of every possible
pair
do we think that this would be a
sufficient test for the sorted built-in
i'm going to go with no because return
the empty list is a great performance
optimization which would pass this test
so we might want to say well if the
output is in order and we have the same
number of elements and we have the same
set of elements as before
then we know that we've sorted the list
correctly
does this one seem right
it turns out this one is also kind of
subtly buggy because if we had the list
for example one two one we could replace
it with the list one two two
which would have the same length the
same set of elements and be in sorted
order but would not be a correct sorting
function
so we could use the mathematical
definition that it's a permutation of
the input such that it's in sorted order
uh the only problem with this one
though it is a full correct test for
sorting is that it's hideously slow so
we'd really want to use the
collections.counter
class and
i think this is a pretty good test for
sorting
in the process we've kind of
rediscovered the idea of property-based
testing
that we can check whether our code is
buggy without needing to know exactly
how to re-implement it
and in this case sorting is fully
specified by just these two simple
properties that the output should be in
order and that the result has the same
elements as the input
i do want to note though partial
specifications even if you can only test
one of these or you can test for some
kinds of bugs but not others still super
useful uh and
more tractable on more complicated kind
of business logic key code
the remaining problem with this is that
no matter how hard you think
many bugs are actually caused by the
interaction of our code with inputs or
situations that we never expected or
never thought of
and
that means that the bit where we have to
write the test cases by hand you know
one two three three two one bca
we're just gonna be stuck there because
if we write all the things we think of
to test
kind of by definition we've probably
also written code that handles the
things we think of
and that's where my library hypothesis
comes in
the job of hypothesis is that if you
describe what kind of data should be
possible hypothesis will find particular
examples that you wouldn't have thought
of
and so here we've written exactly the
same test body but instead of a pi test
parametrized we're saying
from hypothesis use the given decorator
to provide inputs and the argument that
that provides should be either a list of
mixed integers at floats or a list of
unicode strings
and even if this seems like a pretty
direct translation of what we were doing
before this test will fail
and this test fails because there's the
floating point value not a number which
compares unequal to itself
and so it turns out that if you try to
sort a list containing nands python will
sort each of these sub-lists but won't
reorder anything across an n
which is kind of wild but it's unclear
what else the behavior should be
so
the short version is i want you to
be able to and then to actually do it
adopting property based testing
the foolproof plan for that you just pip
install hypothesis you skip the
documentation and then you find a lot of
bugs i hope you're into that kind of
thing
to be more specific like hypothesis has
minimal dependencies just
two pure python libraries that we use
for some data structures uh and it works
on every supported version of python for
the python software foundation from 3.6
to 3.10
it could be cognate installed if you
like conda and so on
so let's have a look at how you would
actually write some tests and when i say
how you would write some tests like the
problem with this one is that you still
have to write the whole thing by hand
and i'm not into that
so let's look at the ghostwriter and a
way to let hypothesis write your tests
for you
once you get around to pip installing
hypothesis
you can check out the hypothesis
shell command and if you ask hypothesis
to write your tests for you you'll see
that there are a bunch of different kind
of things you can do
so you can write things based on type
annotations so they're strictly optional
a bunch of examples you could write in
pi test or unit test style but let's
just jump in let's write a test for our
sorting function
of course that should be sort ed
and so hypothesis spits out a test which
reminds us that the test i wrote by hand
earlier neglected to consider the key
function and the reverse flag
but in the body of the test the
ghostwriter doesn't have any particular
knowledge of sorting so it just calls
the function and hopes it doesn't crash
which is a pretty good start
i would usually use this as a template
to actually extend myself
but you could also tell hypothesis that
the sorted function is item potion that
is if you call it on its output the
result should be the same as the first
one
and so there we are that's a complete
test for sorting
we could also test that our two
functions are equivalent now i don't
have a
trusted equivalent to the sorted
function for the standard library but
the eval built in should be the same as
the ast.literal eval function for every
string which represents a python neutral
so let's see what that test looks like
hypothesis spits out where we have our
global and local namespaces which can be
none or if you want to upgrade the test
a dictionary or a namespace of things
and then we have the node or string and
the source arguments and in this case
that's because the names of the
arguments to a vowel and to literal
vowel actually don't overlap so you need
to edit that down a little and probably
use my hypoth smith project to actually
produce valid source code
but i feel this is a pretty good start
the other cool kind of properties and
this is where the name property-based
testing originated in haskell about 20
years ago
was from properties of things like
binary operators we have associativity
communicativity commutativity identity
elements of sets and so on look to be
honest i don't use this very often but
if your
functions do have these kinds of
properties it should be really easy to
test
we can also have a look at round trips
and this is the last general category of
property and in particular this is the
one that you should probably all think
about going away and using
a round trip property is where you call
a function and you call some other
function that undoes that so in that
case hypothesis goes well if i compress
and then i decompress having found that
matching name in the same module
then i should get back the original
input
this is a really general and really
powerful form of test or design pattern
for tests because we do it all the time
we encode then we decode our data we
serialize it and we deserialize it we
save it to a database and retrieve it
from a database we send it across a
network and receive it from a network
and in each case
these round trips tend to cross a lot of
layers of our stack they tend to operate
on our core data structures and they are
often absolutely crucial to get right
if saving the your data to your database
and bring it back out gives you
different data you have a critical
problem on your hands
so let's look at a more complicated case
than just compression how about json
encoded
so we'll dump it to a string and then
load it back in
and in this case we can see that
hypothesis has found all of the optional
keyword arguments to json encoding and
decoding which i usually ignore
and it turns out there are
many of them
so i've put together just a short test
file which i edited down from that by
hand
where i said well the important bit here
is i just cut out a bunch and i said
that the object is json and that's
defined recursively as the base case for
json is none true or false a number or a
string
or json can be lists of any json or
dictionaries of any string to any json
sounds good
anyone think this will pass or will it
fail
it fails
and here hypothesis actually shows us
two distinct failing examples with
different causes which i think is pretty
cool the first is that if we allowed to
add but then we passed down oh then our
assertion fails because that is not
equal to itself
well that's going to be easy enough to
fix
um but the other one is that if allow
now is false and our json object is
infinity then we get this value error
and when you go and dig into this it
turns out that the json spec doesn't
actually allow non-finite numbers
and if you pass the confusingly named
allowed and flag to false
then
python will reject non-finite numbers in
your json encoding
so to fix that we'll try using the
hypothesis assume function
so first of all we'll say like okay we
just always allow nerd at infinity
and then we'll assume that the object is
equal to itself if this is false it's
kind of like an assertion but the error
just tells hypothesis that that was a
bad example try something else
and if we were on pie test on this one
what do you think we're going to see
still fails
i was very surprised when i first found
this one putting together a talk demo
it turns out that if you have a list
containing not a number it compares
equal to itself
because lists have a number of
performance optimizations inequality
where they try to short circuit things
so
if the list is equal to the other list
by identity then it will always compare
equal by equality as well as a
performance optimization
and for each element if the
corresponding element is equal by
identity it won't bother comparing it by
equality to save you on kind of deeply
nested comparisons
this is usually great but when you have
json and ned it gets pretty confusing
because it turns out even if you call
list
on a list of dead so you get a different
object the element is still the same by
identity and they compare equal unless
you round-trip them through a json it's
kind of bizarre
so the proper way to fix this is
actually just to tell hypothesis not to
generate nan
if we wanted to test the semantics of
json round-tripping with none aloud we
might write a more complicated test
and if we run this one
hypothesis passes and considerably more
quickly because we're not trying to find
that minimal counter example
all right
so much for the ghostwriter
you may however want to port some of
your existing tests rather than just
throwing out absolutely everything and
starting over
uh so i'm going to walk you through what
it might look like to take tests for
something like git which i think of is
kind of business logic in that there's a
lot of just weird arbitrary behaviors of
get uh which match some kind of other
model but you know it deals with state
it deals with files there's not like a
clean algorithmic thing that you could
really do for the user facing part of
git
so let's start with this test which says
that if you check out a new branch that
makes it the active branch which goes we
set up a temporary directory we
initialize the repository we check our
new branch and then that should be the
active bridge
well the first thing we could do to make
this a little clearer is to pull out new
branch as an argument to the test we've
set it as default value so there's no
semantic change but this does make it a
little clearer to the reader that the
specific value of the branch name
shouldn't affect this test
and then if you want to start using a
hypothesis you could say hey hypothesis
generate a branch name which will only
be new branch and run the same test body
still no semantic change and then you
can pull that out into a function shared
about your test suite
and if you've only got a single test
okay this doesn't help much but if
you've got many tests then this means
that you can share
improvements or discoveries about what
kind of data should be valid for
particular sorts of inputs or models
uh
between all of your tests so you get a
kind of m plus n rather than a
multiplicative scaling problem when you
change things
and now we come to the tricky bit where
we actually have to think about what are
valid branch names
because if you run this for example
you'll discover that the empty string is
not a valid branch name
that a
white space only string is not a valid
branch then that git branch names can't
start or end with dashes and a whole
bunch of other complicated constraints
which you can check in the git manual
so for simplicity we could say that a
branch name should consist of only ascii
letters between 1 and 95 characters long
if you go over 95 characters then
certain web hosting things start to
reject your branch name as being too
long
that was a fun one to discover
and then we could come back and look at
this where we're still saying that well
do we really mean that this should only
ever be true with a newly created
repository
so the final test that i would be trying
to migrate towards is something like
this where we say that given any valid
branch name and any repository if we
assume that the branch name is not
already a branch of the repo then we
check it out then that branch name
should be the active branch of the
repository
sounds pretty good to me and i actually
find this test a lot easier to read as
well as a lot more rigorous compared to
the starting point that we found
the final thing i want to talk through
is
coverage guided fuzzing
and this is where
we get a little smarter
the hypothesis engine by default as you
would use it when running your tests or
in ci
has a combination of some feedback and
some really good heuristics plus a lot
of random search
coverage guided fuzzing basically adds
an evolutionary or genetic algorithm to
that
and hypo fuzz is designed to kind of
complement your ci-based workflow
so
your ci workflow or your local test
could then be dedicated to searching for
regressions and you could use this more
powerful approach with extra feedback
to search for new bugs
it's also got this nice feature where
because it uses the same databases
hypothesis to save all of the failing
examples
to reproduce anything it finds can be as
simple as literally just running your
test locally and it can pull that out of
the local file system or redis or
whatever else you want to use
let me pull up a live version of that
that i have
so
here's the live hyperfunds dashboard
where i've set that running on one of my
own projects
uh and if i just zoom in on the early
part of this you can see that there's
this kind of classic pattern where we
logarithmically approach
whatever it is that our steady state
seems to be
but if we really zoom in on one of these
we can see we're still discovering new
behavior new bits of branch coverage as
we go
the big difference that coverage guided
fuzzy makes is that when we discover one
of those very rare branches by chance we
could then try variations or whatever
that thing was because we noticed that
something was different
if you look on a log axis you can kind
of see that you get this more or less
straight line plus the leveling off
later
if we scroll down this has been running
for about half an hour now and
it turns out that this was in fact
sufficient to find a bug in one of my
libraries
yeah i'll go fix that later
so
that's my talk uh
where i wanted to argue that stop
writing tests doesn't actually mean stop
testing but it means that we can hand
over much of the job of testing to
better tools better libraries and spend
perhaps a little less time while still
getting a great deal more rigor
so thanks very much and i'll see you in
the chat for q a
wow